einen corona-satz der in diesen Stunden
eingeschlagen hat wie eine Bombe der
kommt vom Chef des so wichtigen
Robert-Koch-Instituts von Lothar Wieler
und gesagt hatte ihn vor etwas weniger
als 24 Stunden der Vergleich darin
Corona mit der Grippe solcher Vergleich
der galt ja bislang als gefährliche
Verharmlosung der wurde immer den
Querdenkern zugeschoben jetzt also
dieser Satz vom rki-chef der Satz von
Lothar Villa hat ja zwei interessante
Komponenten erstens er soll hier
ausdrücklich benutzt werden um sozusagen
vor der Grippe zu warnen er soll hier
ausdrücklich benutzt werden um
am Ende Menschen Angst zu machen vor
einem nächsten chaotischen Winter um für
die Grippeimpfung zu werben um für
weitere Impfungen zu werden das ist die
eine Komponente das ein Vergleich
herangezogen wird um weiter neue Angst
zu schüren die zweite interessante
Komponente ist das was ihr eben gesagt
habt dass dieser Vergleich bisher
quasi als rechtsextreme verschw Theorie
galt ja Menschen die gesagt haben naja
wie ähnelt sich das eigentlich mit der
Grippe wie vergleichbar ist das mit der
Grippe wie ist es bei der
krankenhausauslastung ganz
entscheidender Punkt Luther wieder
spricht er nämlich von der
krankenhausauslastung das ist schon in
früheren Grippe Saisons volle
Krankenhäuser gegeben hat wie ist das
eigentlich bei wie ist Corona bei der
krankenhausauslastung eigentlich
vergleichbar mit der Grippe da hieß es
immer so wie kann man das das ist eine
Relativierung von Corona das kann man
und es ist sofort sofort jeder der diese
Fragen gestellt hat ist verortet worden
im Lager der wie es dann natürlich immer
sofort heißt rechten der rechtsextrem
der querdenkerszene jetzt stellt sich
unter wieder für die Presse weil er
dafür werben will für die Grippe zu
impfen und hebt quasi die Grippe auf
eine Stufe mit Corona wenn ich mir
überlege wie Menschen in den letzten
anderthalb Jahren für diese Frage dafür
dass Sie sich als medizinische Laien die
Frage gestellt haben sind wir in einer
historischen Ausnahmesituation sind die
Intensivstation wirklich so deutlich
mehr belastet als in einer Grippesaison
wie diese Menschen aus der
Bundesregierung heraus diskreditiert und
teilweise ja ein bisschen zu
kriminalisiert worden sind dann wundert
es mich schon dass das jetzt auf einmal
offenbar die Linie eines
regierungsinstituts ist ja das mit
diesem Vergleich und dieser
Vergleichbarkeit und dieser
Gleichstellung dafür wirkt sich für die
grippeimpfen zu lassen wir sehen neben
dir die Bilder aus der Pressekonferenz
laufen wir schauen jetzt einmal rein was
rki-chef lutal Villa gestern zu einem
Vergleich Grippe und Corona ganz genau
gesagt hat
19 und Grippe auch Influenza genannt die
haben viele Gemeinsamkeiten beides sind
Atemwegsinfektionen beide verbreiten
sich überall dort wo Menschen
zusammenkommen und natürlich auch
besonders in geschlossenen Räumen beide
sind vor allen Dingen für ältere
Menschen und auch für chronisch kranke
Menschen ein Risiko
ein Risiko für ältere und chronisch
Kranke und zwar beide Krankheiten Corona
wie auch die Grippe also direkt der
Vergleich gezogen ein Vergleich den man
sonst eher mit sehr vorsichtigen Fingern
angefasst hat Julian es gibt vor allem
diese interessante Formulierung die sich
überall da verbreiten wo Menschen
zusammenkommen und da glaube ich
entsteht gerade etwas was mir persönlich
Angst macht es hat sich ja ausgebreitet
den anderthalb Jahren Pandemie diese
Besessenheit dass man sich vor allem was
es ein Risiken auf der Welt gibt
irgendwie schützen kann und das auch der
Staat einen irgendwie davor schützen
muss dem ist natürlich nicht so das
Symbol dafür ist natürlich die Maske und
ich erlebe viele Menschen zwischen die
sich diese Maske eigentlich gar nicht
mehr wegdenken können und wollen und das
was Luther Villa da sagt ist natürlich
genau die Vorlage dafür zu sagen naja
mit der Maske das ist doch eigentlich
gar nicht so schlimm und die Grippe
verbreitet sich ja genauso wie Corona
und die Grippe kommt ja auf jeden Fall
und sie ist nicht besiegt und die
Impfquote niedrig warum behalten wir die
Maske nicht dann einfach mal bleibt auf
Twitter aktuell Eltern die ihre Kinder
weiter in die Schule schicken die
maskenpflicht wird jetzt durch die
Eltern durchgesetzt aktuell und nicht
mehr durch die Regierung durch die
Politiker wir haben halt einfach
in zu breiter Weise verliebt in
restriktive Maßnahmen und da kann man
immer nur sagen es braucht Menschen
müssen irgendwann entscheiden normal
weiterzuleben sie können sich nicht auf
Institutsleiter und Politiker verlassen
in das vorzugeben sie müssen sich selber
entscheiden und dieser Zeitpunkt ist
jetzt nein
[Musik]